tidiane mans les vacances le flux les
emporte le reflux les rapporte 10
millions de français ont commencé à se
livrer à un étonnant chassé-croisé qui
va durer cinq jours
partout dans les gares les aérogares il
fallait voir par exemple orly et le
bourget la nuit dernière et ce matin et
surtout sur les routes pour faire le
point j'appelle notre reporter gérard
holtz sur l'autoroute de l'ouest
et bien ici l'autoroute de l'ouest où
vous le voyez la circulation est
importante mais tout se passe bien quand
même tout de suite si vous le voulez le
point sur la circulation sur l'ensemble
de la france la région parisienne
d'abord tout est calme au point de vue
des départs et au point de vue des
arrivées sur le reste les régions de
bretagne de normandie du nord et de
l'est
rien à signaler non plus on circule
assez facilement par contre c'est dans
le sud et en particulier à la frontière
espagnole qu'on signale les retours très
important avec des ralentissements en
particulier à perpignan à sigean à
salses à pézenas aussi où depuis 11h
d'ailleurs en a ouvert le délestage des
corbières il ya même des bouchons entre
béziers montpellier également à
pont-saint-esprit un point à noter à
propos de ces retours c'est la première
fois que l'on voit les vacanciers de
juillet s'y prendre si tôt pour rentrer
et on a même parlé d'étalement des
retours car tout a commencé en fait dès
avant-hier soir
côté sécurité le plan primevère est en
place depuis 9h ce matin trente-cinq
mille policiers et gendarmes sont
mobilisés et puis une nouveauté aussi
six avions de la gendarmerie surveillent
les grands axes pour ceux qui vont
prendre la route une petite explication
si vous voyez des flèches vertes sur le
bord de la route
c est une
itinéraire émeraude cela veut dire que
vous irez un peu moins vite mais vous
serez beaucoup plus tranquille pour
rouler par contre si vous voyez des
flèches jaunes ce sont des délestages là
vous irait aussi vite que sur les grands
axes
parce qu'on a choisi ces routes pour que
la circulation soit plus fluide
un mot sur le temps il sera frais et
nuageux comme vous le savez sur la
partie nord dans le sud le temps sera
beau ensoleillé donc pas de problème de
ce côté là je vais vous rappeler des
chiffres maintenant l'année dernière
pour la même période il y a eu trois
1395 accidents qui ont fait 233 morts
233 personnes qui ne sont jamais ni
parti ni rentrer de vacances
alors pensez à ces chiffres et soyez
prudents avoue jean pierre elkabbach